as sandy goes to work for his 25th start
this year coming off a beautiful
beautiful outing against the san diego
padres seven scoreless and a great
bounce back ozzy albie's in the top spot
and a fly ball out to right field jesus
sanchez
just in front of the track makes the
play here's freddie freeman
and the base hit through the right side
for freddie freeman getting a little bit
closer to 300 average on the year now
this fastball up freddy with that short
compact swing able to get on top of it
noah who's back for the first time since
may 16th
and that's lash to right but solaire is
going to make the play two pitches and
one man out
there's a fastball short hop nice play
freeman andy noah to the bag that takes
care of his son diaz and a nice play
here's adam duvall 230 duval swing and a
miss got him with the slider so sandy
with his first strikeout two down here
in the top of the second this is the
slider and this works away from the
right-handed hitter off the outside edge
here's jack peterson a one-two swing in
a miss got him with another slider so
it's been a lot of sliders nearly going
three balls two strikes pitch on the way
got him looking straight three put the
cutter right over the inside corner he's
looking for the express got the local
instead and he noah has his first
strikeouts like two different sliders
you got the swing and miss one that you
saw early in the count you try to put
him away here he just kind of throws a
3-2 here you go runner at first the
pitch
noah knocks it down has to scramble to
recover and throws a sinker to freeman
who makes the play alfaro's retired good
play by freeman for out number two oh
two pitch
got him swinging
the slider fools alex jackson and wants
curry noah book ends the second inning
with strikeouts sandy alcantra
third strikeout two up two down top of
the order now rojas coming up
it's hit out towards center field right
in line with jack peterson he catches
the line out
and that is out number three lead off
man aboard for the marlins here in the
fourth inning and now brunson's coming
up big news runner goes throw to second
is in time ozzy got the tag down on the
bottom of the footage and the glove was
there before his foot his hand was even
near the base so vote handles a tough
pitch erases issan diaz who's caught
stealing for the first time this year
adam duvall stands in
and he gets duvall again now old for
nine with five k's against alcatra one
down well very similar fashion sandy got
him on a slider working off the outside
edge first time up went right back to it
with two strikes
maybe even a little farther this second
time steven vote with nobody on two out
the one two two out pitch swinging and
miss got him on the changeup so sandy
with his fourth strikeout as jp had
pointed out the first three all on
sliders that time boat swings through
the change another one two three inning
andy out towards center jack peterson
ranging over will make the play peterson
was shaded toward right center but the
way that ball kind of sliced back he
found the glove of peterson
and there's one away a long run for him
shading him to the off field to run it
down the o2 swinging a miss at that one
in the dirt dug out by vote he'll have
to throw him out and he does but that
goes 2-3 and that's strikeout number
three
one of the best hitting pitchers in
baseball
little dribbler tough play anderson
pitcher running low throw throw it away
inoah
get back to the first base bag he turned
left into fair territory he's gonna have
another knock it's gonna be an infield
knock that's it bring up aussie albies
he waves and misses at that changeup
from alcantara his fifth strikeout and
there's one away in the sixth inning
freddie freeman's the battle five career
hits against alcantara
and a shot at the left field of base hit
you got the pitcher running he noah and
the braves will have to stop him good
throw from de la cruz two hits for
freddie freeman and now atlanta's got
first and third with two outs leos
o'reilly ground ball to the shortstop
mickey has it goes a short way to second
they get the fourth shot on freeman and
sandy pitches out of his first mini mess
of the night tyler matsik you see the 14
inning scoreless streak hitters are
hitting .87 against them bases are going
to be loaded for louis brinson
high in the air a little pop dansby foul
groud he's going to slide make the catch
pitcher at third cannot advance
big out sliding grab by swanson who came
up ready to fire just in case two out
dante makes a great play look at him
heads up to be ready good news is he got
alcantra at third he's not going to try
to tag matt sticks one out away from
getting out of this they're loaded with
two out in a 1-2 pitch
got him swinging this time
vote digs it out of the dirt steps on
home plate inning over great job tyler
matson it's chris martin's turn to pitch
and chris martin will face the three
right-handed batters in order for the
marlins here
driven in the air toward right solaire
retreat still going to the middle of the
warning track anderson just missed one
of the hardest hit balls in the night
but right in front of the 335 signs
solaire makes the catch one two
got him swinging strike three slider
solves alex jackson and martin with a
one two three bottom of the seven sandy
through seven four hits no runs no walks
five strikeouts
vote down on strikes another
k for sandy that's his sixth then
there's one away in the eighth
sandy continues to impress third time
through we've seen so much more of this
change up particularly the left-handed
hitters the go-ahead run is a board for
aussie albies runner goes swinging to
miss throwdown to second
knock down by miggy knowing there wasn't
going to be a play smother it make sure
amante doesn't go any further they
strike out two away solaire with two
outs the pitch
that got away from jackson and almante
is going to move up 90 feet one-two
pitch
and a line right base hit the braves
lead
a two-strike hit for solaire plates
abraham almonte and you talk about
manufacturing a run
walk steal wild pitch single and atlanta
scores first finally an
hit that ball off the plate in the
fourth inning for an infield single
swing and a fly ball well hit to right
did riley get enough warning track wall
off the top of the wall it's a solo home
run for austin riley wow is that big
number 26 and his third homer on the
road trip shows you how strong he is he
was out in front of this ball off
balance will smith will take over
he struck him out with a fastball so two
up two down here comes aguilar braves
are a strike away from their 13th
shutout
and strike threes can end it will smith
with a one two three ninth earns his
26th save braves have their 13th shutout